مختلفه من العالم وخاصه بدول اسيا الوسطى
القريبه من الحدود الروسيه واشارنا الى ان
محاولاتنا لمعرفه ما الذي تقوم به هؤلاء
البيولوجيون
العسكريون فكانوا قد كنا قد توجهنا الى
منظمه
الامن البيولوجي والامم المتحده ونحن نسعى
لكي يكون هناك متابعه شفافه لمثل هذه
البرامج
وعلى
هذه هذه القمه كان هناك لقاءات مع دول
مختلفه بامكاني ان اتحدث عن هذا لاحقا
بالتفصيل
استطعتم من
اجراء وصف كامل اللي مفهوم الوضع
وهل تم تطرق الى موضوع اوكرانيا وكيف وكيف
كانت الصيغه ربما انكم لا
تعنونا المعاهده نعم لقد تم التوصل الى
هذه الوثيقه وان النتائجه سيتم اعلانها
غدا خلال لقاءنا
وسيشاركه في ذلك ان تنصل فوازير الماليه
اخواتك
ان هذا هذه الوثيقه ستطرق الى كل المسائل
الذي تم اااا الحديث عنها بما فيها الغذاء
والرقمنا وغيرها من المواضيع الاخرى وهذه
الوثيقه طبعا تم محاوله تاسيسها وتشكيل او
همم وضع الصيغ مختلف باسم الدول القاده
العشرين
وبالطبع همم اذا كان يمكن او توجد الرغبه
الى التطرق الى هذا الموضوع فان هذا يجب
ان يكون في تفويض القادم مجموعه ال 20
فيجب علينا ان نتطرق الى هذا الموضوع
وايضا يوضح بان هناك اختلافات وانه هناك
وجود ايضا للحرب الهجينه الجاريه والتي
تجري على مدى سنوات طويله بدء من لحظه
التي وصلت اليها لحظه الانقلاب الان وصلت
هذه القوه الى السلطه همم هنا ومنذ ذلك
اللحظه فان نعت قد وضعوا ايديهم على
السلطه في الكيف وانتم بالطبع تعلمون كيف
تطورت الاحداث بعد ذلك واي اتفاقيات تم
التوصل اليها
وايضا فيما همم
لوقت حدوث العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
لدفاع عن ادم باسا
الاطراف همم قد اكدوا مواقفهم تجاه هذه
القضيه وما تم مناقشته ضمن لقاءات الامم
المتحده والجمعيه العامه وغيرها من
المنظمات الاخرى وايضا تم التصويت عليها
في اتجاه الجلسه الجمعيه العامه وكانت
التقيمات واضحه ودقيقه همم
فالغرب قد اضاف عباره بانه بانهم قاموا
بادانه همم روسيا ااا
وقد قلنا بان هذا الموقف هو حياتي وهذا
الامر كافي بالطبع لكي يتم التطرق الى هذا
الموضوع بشكل عميق وهنا طبعا في مجموعه
العشرين يجب ان يتم مناقشته مواضيع واعاده
الامور الى مواضعها ويجب وقف
ممارسه هذه
السياسه المعاديه لروسيا في العالم ككل
وانا بدوري قد تطرقت الى ما يمكن فعله من
قبل الزملاء الغرب
على سبيل المثال فما تم منعه همم بلجيكا
تجاه فرنسيين وايضا ما فعلته بريطانيا اذا
ما قد منعت من الايرلنديين من ممارسه
حقوقهم ولغتها فالجواب بالطبع هنا معتم
ياتي من قبلهم وهم يتقيدون بافكارهم وما
يردون الترويج له بشكل خاص وهذا الامر
طبعا يجري من اجل تقويض عمل مجموعه قاده
العشرين وهذا لم يتم همم باستطاعتهم
بالفعل شكرا جزيلا لكم قناه الاولى هل همم
استطعتم هل او او الولايات المتحده لتغيير
مواضيع مجموعه العشرين ايضا هنا واتطرق
فقط الى الموضوع الروسي وهل هناك خلال
لقاءات القصيره كانت هناك نقا- نقاشات
محدده في هذا الطاقه
ما تعرفون فان العمل الاساسي حول المشاكل
الاساسيه الموجوده امام
قمه العشرين كانت قد حددت على مستوى
المختصين والوزراء وهذا العمل معكوسه او
تم عكسه في البيان اما فيما يتعلق
بالموضوع الاوكراني فان الولايات المتحده
وحلفاءها خلال النقاشات اليوم اشاره الى
العدائيه عندما يتم
روسيا بانها قامت باعداء ليس او استفزاء
ليس مستفزا تجاه اوكرانيا وعندما يقولون
ليس مستفزا فانهم دائما
يركدون على ان همم
يعتبر مستفزه من قبالهم وهذا هو محاوله
لحمايه الحدود الروسيه التي كان يقدم هذه
المناطق
والسكان الروسي في منا الجمباز مقاربه
انه عندما كنا نجتمع في الاجتماعات
الحزبيه ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي وليس حتى
في وزاره الخارجيه وانما في ايه شركه او
معمل ويناقشون الخمسينيه
يجب ان يتم اااه
الى الافكار الراسماليه وهذا ما يجري الان
الافكار الامريكيه وهذا ما يجري الى اتجاه
روسيا
اه حول السكان الذين يشكلون ثلاث ارباع
السكان في الكره الارضيه والذين
يدعمون
العالم متعدد اقطاب الذي اقترحه بوتن
وهذا من الصعب
التعامل معه من قبل الشركات العابره
ما الذي يمكن ان يحصل عليه من دعم في هذا
الايطالي
بالظبط
واتبعه لما ينضم الى
العقوبات ضد روسيا
فاذا تطرقنا الى هذا الموضوع ولا يمكن الا
ان يتطرق الى هذا الموضوع لان الغرب دائما
يعتبر الموضوع اوكرانيا اساسا في مناقشاته
والدول العالم تطالب بالتوصل الى السلام
والاتفاق وهم يعرفون تماما ان من يعيق
العمليه في اوكرانيا هو ان القانون
ابي ال امر من زيلانكي بعدم اجراء محادثات
ومفاوضات مع روسيا واليوم خلال
لقاءاتنا مع
الرئيس ماكرون وشولت او خلال اتصالات
القصيره مع الرئيسين كان قد جره هذا
الموضوع
اما حول موضوع
سوف ينتهي صلاحياتها بعد عده ايام فكيف
روسيا تتفق حول هذا الموضوع ان الشروط
بسيطه وهي مذكوره في الاتفاقيه الاولى
التي
مكونه من جزءين
الحبوب الاوكرانيه
القوات المسلحه
الانساني
وعده بانهم لم يقوموا بذلك مره اخرى زملاء
انا في تركيا
يدعم اوكرانيا باي شكل وجزء الاخر من
الاتفاقيه هو تصدير الحبوب الروسيه وهنا
يجب اعطاء دور الامين العام للامم المتحده
رغم انهم مره خمسه اشهر على هذا الموضوع
ولكن ليس هناك من نتائج واليوم وكان
الحديث عن تلك الوعود التي قدمتها
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي على
الورق
وهناك
نوايا لانجازها فهذا يمكن ان ينهي تلك
العقبات امام تصدير الحبوب الروسيه ولكن
الامر ليس متعلق فيها الاوراق وانما كيف
سوف تنجز على ارض الواقع
اسطوانه ان الامين العام يعتمد على زملائه
في الدول الغربيه وان من هو
الامر الذي يتعلق باولئك الذين سوف
يستخدمون لتصدير الحبوب الروسيه فان
العقوبات
حتى السفن الروسيه الى المرافق الاوربيه
البنك الزراعي وايضا ضمان
التامين لهذه السفن كل هذه الوعود مكتوبه
وامل انها سوف تنفذ وعلى الاغلب فان
الامين العام لما المتحده اليوم اكد انه
سوف يضع هذه المسائل في الاولويه
رمز
حولكم عفاف الاون الاخيره هم يغيرون
بلاغاتهم اتجاهها روسيا ونحن نبدا دائما
يبدا بالكلمات التي تعبر عن السلام
والمفاوضات دائما ورفع العقوبات فكل هذا
ما النتائج التي تم التوسل اليها بالنسبه
همم
اا على كل هذه الامور فانا روح الاتحاد
الاوروبي وما هناك هم همم
يتجهون بطريق اخر وكما قلت للسي الرئيس
همم ماكرون اف همم هو دائما يقول بانه
دائما خلال الاتصالات مع بوتن بانه سيقوم
بتسويه الوضع والوصول الى اتفاق واليوم
قلت لهم بانني اذكركم بكل ما قلته فانا
المشكله كلها واقعه على الجهه الاخرانيه
ومتعلقه طبعا بهم ونحن جاهزونا دائما
باجراء المفاوضات ولكن ربما هذا الامر هو
غير واقعي في وضعنا وفي القضيه
الاتحاد الاوروبيه قد
اعلنتجها لجنه المحدده
للموجوده في تلك المنطقه
فبرايكم ما
ستوجه
الازمه مع اوكرانيا وما سيجري هناك في هذا
الطاقه اعتبر بان الاتحاد الاوروبي
هم مشاركون هجنيون في هذه الازمه وفي هذه
الحرب الموجوده في اوكرانيا بما يقومون به
من نقل الاسلحه والتدريب هناك وكل ما الى
ذلك من مساعدات يقومون بتقديمها بما في
ذلك تقديم المعلومات الاستخباريه
وايضا ما تمارسه امريكا والولايات المتحده
فهذا كلهم مثبت والديهم هناك همم الاف
المرتزقه الذين يقومون بنقلهم وارسالهم
الى هناك وفيما يتعلق
بالمهمه او لجنه التدريب التي يقومون
ويودون بتشكيلها هناك
وكما قلت لمكرون وشلز وغيرهم حول ضروره
التحول الى تسويه سلميه الان والى حد اقصى
فهذا التداول الثنائي في التعامل او ال
مضاد غير مفيد وهذا الامر الان يجري بشكل
دائم في العلاقات الدوليه ولكننا نتعود
على ذلك بالتدريج بطبع